this bear is gonna some people up
[Music]
when I first heard about cocaine bear I
just remember thinking it's a hell of a
title A Bear okay it's a cocaine bear
comedy
but scary we have
good luck in nature
it's so out there and bizarre and the
real story is out of control millions of
dollars worth of cocaine fell from the
sky Andrew Thornton second this
notorious drug Runner he threw bags of
cocaine
into the Appalachian Mountains the drug
dealer went to go find the duffel bags
but what found it first was a black bear
the bear had consumed 70 pounds of
cocaine
and what happens when all these
characters come together in the
Chattahoochee Forest the bags worth 14
million I'm looking for my daughter
bears are very peaceful creatures you're
safe Bears can't climb trees of course I
can
pouring comedy are like two sides of the
same coin I'd love to not remember this
but it kind of seems like the thing that
stays with a man forever I essentially
make comedies and I put them inside of
other movies and this is a comedy inside
of a horror movie I I don't like this
please stop I've gotten the opportunity
a few times to work for actors turned
directors and EB is just wonderful she
loves improvisation and she has this
unique feel of what is funny and what is
true the bear did cocaine
a bear did cocaine
this is exactly what I think would
happen if a bear was on cocaine
[Music]
there you go girl yeah
the bear it loves cooking
[Music]
why are you shooting at me